you know you you think well I hope you
know this isn't the fall of Rome I hope
it's not the historians aren't going to
say how could they been so selfish so
self-serving I suspect I suspect we will
be seen as selfish it's we are so glad
pneus in a way that it doesn't look good
especially god forbid in a future era
where people aren't kantik showers every
morning you know we will be seen as I'm
miss pigs but I hope not I hope we make
it so that everyone can have a hot
shower every morning and a good
breakfast in a good school and then
they'll think of us as I'm proud for
bears you know I we I don't think
they're going to think of us like we
think of the founding fathers of this
country or you know people who really
put themselves in the line and fought
and you know earn these rights and then
you know top late in the night about big
ideas where they're not going to think
it was like that you know it's our fault
and you know where they were the
indulgent grant worthy indulged
grandchildren